long information and do other things
about the national football league and
let's begin with the everson griffin
trade of all the teams out there
that
i would have thought may have been in on
everson griffin
the last on the list maybe one spot
above the vikings
would have been the lions but the lions
are three and three don't look now but
the lions are contenders don't look now
but the lions threw a conditional sixth
round picked at the cowboys to get
everson griffin off the books
don't look now but the lions
the i think this is the first time the
lions have made any type of an all-in
move since barry sanders retired
i mean i can't really remember them
making any moves yeah in recent history
certainly you know and again hey they're
hanging around three and three we've
we've seen them flirt with beating the
new orleans saints certainly
could it be chicago week one probably
should have right so you sit there and
you look at it from their perspective
they're going wait
we're close to being in this thing we're
not giving up quite yet
and i think one of the big issues they
have on their defense in general hey is
yeah they don't have play makers they
got a lot of big people up front but
other than trey flowers who's been a
little underwhelming as a pass rusher
for what they've paid them they've paid
him like a top-tier pass rusher and
football i think they realized if they
wanted a chance to make a play at this
thing they needed to upgrade their front
four a little bit and be able to hey
it's third down we can get after you a
little because patricia likes to play
coverage so i understand it from that
standpoint and you're right i mean we're
kind of sleeping on the lions but
uh they're quietly kind of just hiding
under the radar there
and you know the seahawks are the team
that we would have immediately pegged as
someone that should be trying to get any
help that it can at past russian there
was a point in the offseason
where everson griffin was linked right
the seattle seahawks
and if it's conditional six if that's
all it takes i'm assuming that jerry
jones who is a master of negotiation
would have at least tried to get the
seahawks to the table what do you care
if you trade into the seahawks you're
not competing with the seahawks to win
your division just like you're not
competing with the lions
to win your division if anything
to the extent that you hope there's a
way to get a wild card berth you should
be more concerned about the lions than
the seahawks anyway i'm i just wonder
where the seahawks in this because at
the end of the day you're not talking
about very much to get everything
griffin for the stretch run no it is not
a lot you're right i mean for a six
rounder i mean wow it's that's basically
like you're saying it's nothing um
i will say this though
you know the the play has not been
overwhelming or gonna pop out to you
about everson griffin i know what's he
got mike two and a half sack something
like that maybe uh right around that
range but he is not a guy that is going
to be brought in either to be a starter
i don't think at this point you know
maybe if a team starts the game out and
three wide receiver four wide receiver
sets and you go oh we're pretty
confident they're going to come out
throwing the football and doing those
type of things
but you know as far as every down
playing and all those type of things no
i think he's going to be a guy that's
just going to be specifically about pass
rush and you know he's not the same
player he was a few years back but but i
still
don't understand seattle maybe not
getting involved in the conversation or
maybe they did and just they weren't
willing to part ways with the six-round
pick
yeah you know that that uh may have been
what ultimately happened at the end of
the day that's not what they want to do
they don't want to take on roughly six
million i think that's a combination of
salary and per game roster bonuses and
that was the motivation for the cowboys
to get rid of those numbers because that
six million dollars now can be banked
for next year when they're trying to
sign dak prescott or otherwise put a
team around
dak prescott and try to be better than
they are this year who else now that we
have crossed that bridge and the cowboys
are selling off assets
and and i i don't think it's a fire sale
i think it's a calculated decision based
on
here's a guy that we can do without and
we can create some cap space for the
future
and it's not going to significantly
undermine our ability to try to win one
of the worst divisions we've seen in
years who else would fall into that
category we heard a few names at the top
of the show don terry poe was one that
was mentioned
anyone that jumps out to you that the
cowboys should be willing to part with
chris i mean
they got a a plethora of wide receivers
so i wonder where if they would got the
right offer for
i mean i don't amari cooper i don't know
maybe is amari cooper on the table i'm
just throwing it out there for all the
money he's making and that would be a
stunner they just signed i know well the
fact that they have cd lamb and michael
gallup and you know cedric wilson who's
popped up a many times this time this
year i just i thought a receiver
position because they have like an
embarrassment of wealth there now i
don't know i thought that yesterday too
right i thought but but gallup's in the
last year of his contract and i think
he's a guy you want to try to find a way
to keep that around that's what i would
think yes
what you're looking at if you would move
on from amari cooper you would be facing
an 8 million dollar cap charge next year
okay but also avoiding
a 20 million dollar salary right for
next year now that could be restructured
and you know there's ways to kick the
can but you pick up 12 million in net
cap space for next year if someone would
offer you and i don't know that mark
cooper is getting a first round pick for
anyone at this point but last year
mohamed sanu got a second round pick so
who the hell knows that's right if
someone offers you a first round pick
for amari cooper and you can dump 20
million in salary for next year pick up
12 million in net cap space
maybe you do it chris i i would
seriously think about it i would with
the cowboys team that we've seen here
that clearly wasn't as good on paper as
we thought and there's major holes
everywhere throughout the football team
let alone like you're mentioning the the
juggling of the salary cap issues and
all that and then yeah some of these
guys cd lambs he's he worked out he's
you know it's not a bust he's going to
be one of your top two receivers for the
next five years guaranteed that's it you
don't have to worry about it anymore
michael gallup really could fit into
that role too and yeah he's at a very
manageable price right now hasn't put up
stats to be able to command a big
payday when he does become a free agent
i mean if the cowboys were smart they'd
get out in front of that and try to sign
him some you know it somewhat here in
the near future but yeah amari cooper's
the guy that came to my mind mike he is
he's a hell of a football player we know
there are teams that have wide receiver
needs out there and i just wondered you
know yeah okay cowboys maybe they're
chalking it up a little bit and going
let's play for next year you know even
if we get in the playoffs this year and
win our division what are we really
building on you know i mean okay hey
yeah all right we still might get in but
are we really that good who gives a damn
so i think they're starting to kind of
re rebuild as we speak right now
there's another guy on offense yeah and
shereen williams and i kicked this
around last night on pft pm just as the
news broke of everything griffin well i
know guy who got a big contract last
year
not this year yeah last year right now
here's the thing who's taking that
contract nobody
that's the thing i don't think anybody
is right
with with the way he's looked the last
two years and then the years he is in
his career you know as far as where he's
at i just have a hard time right at
least i do thinking that somebody's
gonna pony up
you know a pretty good trade
trade value to get him or whatever
assets to trade to get him and then also
pay him that type of money i mean i
would think le'veon bell and anything
like that would scare the hell out of
anybody from doing those type of things
by the way michael gallup signed through
2021 21 more reason not to let him go
base salary of 750 this year
9 20 next year you don't trade him no
when you consider how good he has been
yeah elliot is one that would be
fascinating if there was a team out
there if we could spin back the clock to
1989 and there was a team like the
vikings that was just a running back
away
from being a super bowl contender all
they need all they need is herschel
well that's all they needed and all they
needed was to give up three first round
picks three second round picks and a
bunch of players and it was just a
disaster i'm looking at the elliott
contract now he's signed through 2026
good lord
it would be it would be a a significant
cap charge next year for them to move on
a lot easier for them to move on from
amari cooper frankly than to move on
from ezekiel the way that that deal was
structured so uh look i i i don't know
how motivated they're going to be
but you know that's the balance maybe
you're not motivated until somebody
makes you an offer for a guy that you
weren't thinking about trading but all
of a sudden hey it looks like a pretty
good deal so maybe we
will do it what about the lions right do
we see them doing anything more is this
really the start of an all-in play or is
it just kind of a fluke thing i i mean i
i wouldn't
their jobs are on the line their butts
are on the line they got a chance you
know to to make a little run here when
you look at their schedule
you know i know they got the colts this
week okay yeah i'm sure the colts are
favored by a little but we've seen the
colts you know trip and stumble this
year but after that when you go colts
vikings football team carolina panthers
then the texans and then the bears again
you know i mean that's that's that's
favorable i don't look at that schedule
for the lions and just go damn they're
out of it i go whoa they could end up
winning you know three to the next five
games four to the next five games and
all of a sudden we're we got a different
view of them
maybe i guess that doesn't count as pft
bingo when he i don't know it doesn't
seem like it does not not to your extent
it's only when you do it
uh but mike i don't know i mean i i
think
i can't imagine maybe another db if
there was somebody out there that was
you know worth it maybe they would get a
top corner they're always looking for
cover corners out there and then maybe
still another difference maker up front
you know if that if that opportunity
presented itself
oh you know the belichick approach is
grab a guy who's in the last year of his
contract so that
you get potential compensatory draft
consideration if he leaves as a free
agent after the year so you give up you
know a three or a four to get a guy
and if you don't keep him depending upon
how old he is and a lot of other factors
including how many free agents you sign
next year versus how many you lose you
could end up getting back some of the
draft capital that you gave up to get
him that's one of the things belichick
is very very big on doing and matt
patricia the coach of the lions was with
belichick for years so that's part of
the analysis guys getting toward the end
of a contract with no real expectation
they're going to stick around in the
city that they have been that that is
something that could happen and remember
today and tomorrow
are really the hot spots big days for
trade activity if you want a guy to be
available in week nine if you wait until
the deadline next week of tuesday the
guy's not going to be available come
sunday just like everest and griffin
right deal was done tuesday he's not
available this week his first game for
the detroit lions will be week nine
at the minnesota vikings he's gonna play
him anyway with the cowboys yeah right
but what it what an introduction to the
lions hello minnesota i'm coming back to
see you and look the guy's been a great
leader i still think he's got some gas
in the tank and clearly the lions do as
well yeah but uh interesting development
yesterday the trade went down and that
it happened
with the detroit lions not the seahawks
or another contender that is more of an
immediate top of the stack this is a
team that's going to be in it and this
is a team that could use some help
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports